in the baseball free agency period that
is underway has none other than the
following up for free agency Zach
Britton Carlos Gomez Gio Gonzalez Matt
Harvey Jeremy Hellickson Greg Holland
Matt Holliday Dallas Keuchel Mike
Moustakas Matt Wieters and oh yes Bryce
Harper and that's just a partial part of
the list the founder owner and president
of the Boras corporation Scott Boras
here in the Rich Eisen show how are you
Scott anything going on
good morning rich how are you anything
going on in your life anything up just
just just a wonderful Tuesday morning ah
very good what was your first client
Scott who was your first one did you
represent it you know my teammates Keith
Hernandez and Bill Caudill and then a
hometown friend Mike Fischer and they
all kind of reached out to me when I was
I just graduated law school after three
knee operations and we I was working at
a law firm in Chicago and and it all
rather surprisingly started a rather
momentous and privileged career that I
have and so Keith Hernandez Hernandez
was a guy who what he was with the Mets
aware was at the Cardinals at the time I
mean he was with the Cardinals at the
time and and then we you know we've
known one another for a long time and I
actually played with Keith's brother
Gary and so we we knew the family and
and and then my teammate bill Caudill
you know advance to the big leagues and
Mike Fisher knew there's played the big
leagues for about eight or nine years
all those guys reached out to me because
of our you know our relationships in the
past and playing together so it it had
really opened the door that I did I
didn't really anticipate a plan for do
didn't you really you you wanted to be a
ballplayer yourself right you wanted to
start playing well you know and
obviously when you you know when I was
playing I was always a pretty good
and then you know you you know when
you're you kind of get the Double A and
you're you're close to big leagues and
then all of a sudden you you have your
first neon but back then they didn't
have arthroscopic surgery right so you
have your first knee operation your
second the operation your third knee
operation and all of a sudden you're in
law school and rather quickly now here
we are in 2018 and everyone wants to
know what's happening with Bryce Harper
Scott so let me just get right to it
here what is happening with Bryce Harper
is you and I are conversing right now
well you know as with all three agents
what ownership does they sit down and
meet with you and discuss the
opportunities the futures our franchise
and you know for create some players
they they sit in rooms for three or four
hours and hear presentations from teams
and you know have discussions about you
know what choices they have ahead up in
their future so it's it's a it's a
process we have to limit you have to
kind of in Bryce's case you certainly
have to limit the number of teams that
are on the list of meetings and but it
is a it's something that I think for a
player you you sign and and in fact you
you it's almost eight or nine years
before you have the right to do this so
it's a long-awaited right and really
something I think every player looks
forward to because they get to hear
about the futures of organizations and
how they fit in and you know it's a very
valued choice for for a player to make
so when you say you limit the number of
teams that are going to sit down with
him what's the number well we really
don't go into that because it becomes a
a defined lottery if you will because
the the way light we do is we just kind
of sit down and say the teams that
unless unless something occurs
differently in the future he's going to
meet with an initial round of teams and
then if he's not pleased with you know
what he's heard
you know he'll certainly reach out to
you but when you're when you're kind of
a knight when you're in a generational
player which is a rare free agent
somewhat is that young and and has
really through this performance
established a record that would say that
you're going to be a Hall of Famer
because every player has done what Bryce
has done prior to age 25
they are Hall of Famers and so the and
then there's the other aspect of it for
him that is different because he's
iconic he's demonstrated in the
franchise you increase his franchise
value
he puts additional fans in the seats and
the TV ratings are are dramatically
higher once he's on a team rather than
that they were before it so all these
things play and they're the into the
mainstream how you appropriately
evaluate him okay value declare so in
terms of the pool of Possible's for for
Bryce Harper let me let me just walk
through this door here there was a
report that he turned down and you guys
turned down a contract offer a
significant one from the Nationals at
the end of the playing season while they
were still an exclusive bargaining right
with him
is that a fact well I would say that the
negotiations with the Nationals
continued and certainly the Nationals
have approached Bryce while he was under
their employee to discuss the future
relationship a lot of things they're
reported aren't particularly accurate
but the the truth the matter is they
deal in Chile expressed interest and
continue to expressed interest in
returning Bryce to their franchise so is
it fair to say the fact that he turned
down that offer is as you point out a
long-awaited right to hear from
everybody is that the reason why well I
would say that in the relationship a lot
of times teams want to begin a
discussion the Nationals had an advance
on that because I'm
rules they could begin discussions and
so as to whether or not you know where
those discussions go it's just a
continuum so there's not been any
decisions made yet because we had to
review a whole host of teams and
evaluate the process but certainly that
the the right of free agency is is it's
just something that it takes literally
the bargain agreement says six but the
way they manipulate the rules it's
really seven years once you're in the
big leagues letting players have
minor-league service so it's a it's a
right that it takes almost a decade to
get to for most players and so it's it's
really something that you want to review
before you make any final decisions okay
a couple more questions on this Scott
Boras agent of Bryce Harper and more
here on the Rich Eisen show so he has
not taken any sit-down meetings with any
teams yet oh no no we're we're very deep
in the process on that with many many
clubs and and we're still you know
reviewing you know a number of the
team's opportunities and so yeah the
process has been unfold since November
okay so we are down the road here what's
the timeline is there a timeline here
Scott give me I took it it's of course
that something is up to Bryce and and
the team that he you know pursues to
final but you know as you get into this
you it just takes a while to get through
that volume of teams and once we once
we've completed that I think there's
opportunities to begin making decisions
and and have advanced discussions
probably you know usually it takes
sometimes the process can be two weeks
and sometimes it can be three months so
it's really hard to determine what the
timetable is because it depends on
really both sides making directive
decisions as to how to achieve a all
that all the wants of each each
Club Inquirer and let's if you don't
mind run down a few other players of
yours right now Dallas Keuchel is quite
an interesting arm and player and
individual and what he's meant to the
Astros organization what's the market
for him
Scott well he's the modern-day Tom
Glavine and Andy Pettitte he is a great
postseason record has the ability to win
big games in the postseason which in
today's world is very very valuable
you know Mike Moustakas also has that
characterization about him where he's
his you know a power hitting third
baseman who's got a great record of
winning big games and getting big hits
and so when you when you look at those
players that have postseason a resume of
success in the postseason and they have
rings on their fingers
I think ownership looks at them not only
as someone that can add to the
performance record of their team during
the season but really give you that that
that special dynamic that you want the
locker room that players who've never
been there before can rely upon and in
baseball when you play the game every
day the locker room is all the more
important because it is a it's kind of
Groundhog Day and where you're you're
not there once a week and you're there
every day and so what goes on in the
locker room and what what a player
brings in the locker room has a great
deal more impact than a lot of other
sports that don't play every day so and
that postseason run it seems like you
are you are for the 30 days you are
you're in the locker room you are
traveling you're you're together and the
day-to-day attitude of the club is is
extremely important to get optimum
performance out of players and it's
interesting I mean you talk about the
clubhouse and what attitudes are and
things of that nature a player that
could once have been described as the
next Tom C
her modern-day tom seaver and Matt
Harvey as we all know finally parted
ways with the Mets and vice versa
what do you tell prospective employers
about Matt Harvey and his mental state
readiness to compete and try and get
back to that status of being the next
Tom Seaver Scott well the the fact that
you've done it is huge in these
processes because you know it exists
you're not you're not advocating
something may happen you've known it has
happened and so consequently with Matt's
case it was really about his physicality
because you know he put his career on
the line after Tommy John surgery and
and and so the betterment of his team
certainly went beyond doctors
recommendations with the number of
innings that he threw and the result of
that was another injury where he had to
have it
thoracic outlet surgery and that surgery
which encumbers nerves it's it just
takes time for a player to get his
command back and certainly the last half
of this season that's command came back
when he got traded over to Cincinnati
you really saw him get back to 96 97
miles an hour and velocity and but the
key thing is is that the consistency
with his command going forward was ever
improved and so illustrating that and
getting back physically was I think a
key watermark for for Matt and for
owners to know and the fact that if he
has that kind of capacity physically I
think everyone knows mentally what he
can do because he's already Illustrated
that if healthy he can be a number one
for a team and take it to the places
that most owners desire Ron Scott before
I let you go I do want to give you the
the floor here on my show of subject you
and I have discussed off air
and that is the shift in major league
baseball and how you feel it is
particularly biased against one
particular type of hitter and I give you
the floor on your thoughts on the shift
in Major League Baseball Scott Boras
well thanks rich this is
we've now are able to get the front row
of Dodger Stadium to your awesome great
very happy about I might add just that
I've never seen I've never seen anyone
who is behind the mic eat as many hot
dogs in a game as you did well you know
Scott those Dodger dogs I don't know I
don't know I don't know how you lay off
them Scott I'll be honest man yeah I
mean well it's it's a grant frankly I
was so impressed that it distracted me
from the game I will be on credit it's
the numbers thing with the ship and that
is that because the first base you can
literally put four men on me you know
the right side of the infield and you
can say that a left-handed hitter who
particularly power hitters who make
their living driving a baseball and
hitting it hard because the goal of
baseball always is if you hit the ball
hard you should be rewarded and and
that's that's the hardest thing to do in
sport we want to hit a 95 mile an hour
fastball hard and so these these men who
have power are used to and trained to
hit the power and that's what gets them
to the big leagues and gives them an
elite value and they want homeruns they
want power and so they're taught to to
basically pull the baseball and and
develop a power swing so when they get
to the big leagues you always hear the
everyone say well go the other way do
the things they need to do well the
answer is to go the other way that means
that you're going to have more likely
than not a lot of pitches that have to
be on the outside part of the plate that
it has to be in the middle part of the
plate so that you can direct the
baseball but remember these men are not
paid to direct the baseball they're paid
to hit it from power now when you have a
right-handed
he can come up and he gets sliders and
fastball biggest sliders fast most throw
it away
but more importantly breaking balls and
the slider the breaking ball are usually
balls that are coming at you and then
veer towards the the outside part of the
plate and so consequently some 75% of
the pitchers and baseball are
right-handed it is much easier for a
right-hander to go the other way because
the pitches they receive all breaking
balls allow them to document a swing
that they've been trained to do to hit
the ball the other way
left-handed hitters sue 75% of time
faced right-handed pitching want to run
a breaking ball from a right-handed
pitchers coming in on their hands or a
fastball is throwing in they are trained
to pull the baseball so you're going to
see far less opportunity hit the ball
the other way by just merely that the
number of right-handed pitchers versus
left and the other aspect of it is
because that you have literally you can
put the third baseman right behind
second base giving four infielders on
the right side whereas when a
right-handed hitters up you can only put
two infielders on that side because you
have to have the second baseman on the
other side of the bag to turn the
DoublePlay and the first baseman
obviously has to remain their first base
so you can see that I used the term
discriminatory because it is a four
player versus two player dynamic member
right-handed versus left-handed on the
defender side well not a single manager
I've spoken to Hinch who else
Brockman Cora Roberts none of them would
be up for a rule saying that you got to
have two guys on each side of the bag
but by the start of the pitch or one
foot in the infield none of them they
love it they love this shift well if I'm
a manager it gives me certainly more
control of the game because it takes
left-handed power and minimizes it so
that I have to play a station-to-station
baseball which managers love because it
gives them more control but the big
leagues is about power fans love power
and when you train players they hit for
power
and you certainly don't want the major
leagues to be something different than
it is at all other levels of baseball
well Scott I really appreciate the time
and I got to be honest with you I feel
like a left-handed hitter talking about
Bryce Harper I think you put four guys
on the side of right side a second base
and and you shifted me I mean I don't
know I don't know what I don't I don't
know what to get here I mean no I mean
you got something I mean it's does the
name of the team rhyme with Willie's I
mean rank ease I mean what do you got
for me Scott
come on well I think the truth of it is
is that if they continue with the ship
there's going to be a lot more famous
announcers eating hot dogs we're going
to have left to watch for power before
first of the year do we seek before you
can wait are you seriously are you gonna
wait from a charter to sign first is it
waiting right I don't think I don't
think that Machado has anything to do
with Bryce Harper I think it has to do
with the fact that you know just you can
never predict how this process unfolds
because owners make the decisions as to
when players sign contracts and and how
they how advanced they want to be in a
negotiation so sometimes they happen
I've had many times happen in November
and I've had many and at a recent time
we've had them happened in March so it's
it's a it's something that is probably
more unpredictable than than ever as to
the timing of these days Scott really
appreciate the time let's chat again
soon I'd love to have here in the Los
Angeles studio when you're up here all
right rich always a pleasure gives me my
bed I will thank you that's much
appreciated that's Scott Boras so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience